всім привіт ми з вами не на острові
загиблих кораблів
пам'ятайте таку книгу класну це місто
Одеса, Україна
пляж дельфіни ось перед вами ви можете
побачити ось це найбільша пам'ятка
корупції в Україні довжина 59 метрів
ширина 10 водотоннажність 1600 тонн це
бункерів щик delphi
корабель що прибило кілька днів
назад до одеської затоки
він перевалився через хвилеріз і затонув
прямо тут на пляжі в одесі ви бачите
скільки людей і таке селфі
паломництва люди ходять фотографуються
а що це таке ще раз повторюся це
пам'ятник тієї корупції яка як
сказав гончарук прем'єр-міністр вже в
україні немає ось її немає а пам'ятник ось
такий ось буквально зовсім недавно
з'явився
про що йдеться є така схема завезення
нелегального палива контрабандного
палива в Україну означає приходить танкер
з російським паливом та країни-агресора
це перша більша частина таким чином перший
великий танкер наводить
привозить палива переливає його в
друга ланка ось у такі танкери як
бункерів щоки малі танкери
можна назвати як ви їсте даному випадку
то корабель ними зветься delphi
він під прапором був відомий флот Молдови
молдавський приписаний порту джорджу лише
ти і ось цю другу ланку вони приймають
обсяг палива за такими кораблями
великий танки розливають палива за такими
ось невеликим танкером і вони стоять за
межами територіальних вод України
є нейтральних водах стоять ну вони
обслуговують кораблі, які проходять
повз них можуть залити паливо але головне
суть не в цьому головне в тому, що є
третя ланка а це такий вже москітні
флот всяких котирування чирків які
підходять до нього та нейтральних водах
заливають палива ось це контрабандна
далі по організованому разом з
держприкордонслужби та друзі мій канал а не
завозять це паливо на берег зараз це
все працює в районі порту очаково та
там зливають його вже у бензовози
і остання ланка бензовоза це розводять
за заправками і далі це паливо
заливається в українську 4 колісні
залізні коні та
на цьому паливі їздять українці на
контрабандному паливі з якого не
сплачені податки ось вся схема
може існувати без участі
держприкордонслужби і ось ось і приклад де
заяви володимира зеленського нам же
сказали, що вся корупція переможена
скрізь вже призначені ним чиновники де
ось я показую вам конкретний приклад
ось цей пам'яті кантер лежить у місті
одесі блокувальник delphi
пам'ятник відсутності корупції при
президенті всесвітньому запам'ятайте
корупції звичайно немає ну а танкер dolfi
є тепер нова прикраса одеської
береги та новий артефакт
практично знаєте наші якісь десь
знаходять підводні міста античні а у
нас є ось такий ось блокувальник
delphi
але теж практично античний але з дуже
яким конкретним змістом ось так ось